vacunas de rn m para la cob y 19 las
vacunas son sustancias que lo protegen
de enfermedades perjudiciales la mayoría
de las vacunas contienen partes de
gérmenes debilitados o muertos que
activan el sistema inmunitario para
combatir la enfermedad pero las vacunas
de rn m para la cob y 19 son diferentes
contienen una sustancia llamada ere nm
que le enseña a las células a fabricar
una proteína que desencadena una
respuesta inmunitaria para entender cómo
funcionan estas vacunas es importante
saber que es el rm y cómo fabrica
normalmente las proteínas que el
organismo necesita la mayoría de las
células del cuerpo tienen un centro de
mando en su interior llamado núcleo
contiene material genético llamado adn
que consiste en instrucciones para
construir y mantener el organismo las
proteínas son uno de los componentes
básicos del organismo cuando hay que
construir una nueva proteína corporal
las instrucciones para construirla se
copian del adn de la célula y se
convierten en un mensaje llamado
mensajero o
fnm a continuación el aire nm sale del
núcleo y se dirige a una máquina de
construcción de proteínas de la célula
llamada ribosoma a medida que el
ribosoma lee el mensaje del snm
construye la proteína que el organismo
necesita las vacunas de rn m aprovechan
este proceso para ayudar a dar inmunidad
contra el hobbit 19 cada vacuna contiene
un arn especial que proporciona
instrucciones para que las células
construyan una pieza inofensiva del
virus llamada proteína espiga la
proteína espiga se encuentra en la
superficie del corona virus sars co2 que
causa el kobe 19
cada trozo de arn de la vacuna está
envuelto en una capa protectora la
vacuna se administra en forma de
inyección en la parte superior del brazo
en el cuerpo las partículas de aire nm
entran en sus células una vez dentro de
la célula el aire
viaja hasta un ribosoma utilizando el
arn de la vacuna el ribosoma solo
fabrica una parte de la proteína espiga
del virus después de fabricar el trozo
de la proteína espiga la célula destruye
el arn de la vacuna
es importante saber que el arn de la
vacuna nunca entra en el núcleo de la
célula ni cambia el adn de ninguna
manera
a continuación la célula presenta el
trozo de la proteína espiga en su
superficie esto permite que las células
inmunitarias detecten la proteína y
reconozcan que no debe estar allí
como resultado las células inmunitarias
comienzan a producir anticuerpos como
parte de la respuesta inmunitaria al
virus en el futuro si se contrae el
virus los anticuerpos reconocen y se
adhieren a las piezas de proteína espiga
de las células infectadas y a las
proteínas espiga del virus esto los
marca para su destrucción inmediata por
parte de otras células inmunitarias como
todas las vacunas la ventaja de estas
vacunas de adn m es que proporcionan a
las personas vacunadas protección contra
el virus sin tener que enfermarse de
kobe 19 la mayoría de las vacunas de arn
para kobe 19 requieren una segunda
inyección al cabo de unas semanas en
algún momento después de recibir la
vacuna puede tener síntomas como fiebre
esto es normal significa que la vacuna
está funcionando para hacerlo inmune el
virus las vacunas lo protegen a usted a
su familia y a su comunidad de
enfermedades que pueden ser peligrosas o
incluso mortales para obtener
información actualizada sobre las
vacunas contra la cob y 19 visite el
sitio web de los centros para el control
y la prevención de enfermedades en
punto gov